I mean, I have, like, very specific investments in the particular reading that I've been pushing.
And I noticed that, especially in the last episode, I was kind of, I was forcefully pushing that and I was kind of guiding the conversation towards my project, which, whatever, I think that was okay for the scope of that conversation.
I do kind of want to allow your guys' interpretations to breathe a little bit, maybe, in some of these upcoming episodes, because I've just, at least, it's almost like a self-preservation thing for me.
It's like, I don't want to steer too far away from the line that I've kind of cultivated, because you brought up all these interesting points about the potentially more interesting versions of Barad.
And I'm just, like, I mean, I grant that, but I'm also, like, I'm going to stick to this kind of version of critique, because this is what's been generative for me, right?
At this moment, that is what's been driving me to write, and it's that, that's kind of confrontation with the text.
But again, I don't have to do that in these conversations.
You know what I mean?
Like, there can be a difference between us talking through it and then me writing it, but I've just been, like, forcing that sort of, I don't know.
No, but I have no, certainly for me, it's great that we come with directions.
Otherwise, you know what I mean?
So, like, I hadn't, there's no problem with it.
I recognize the moments, like, in our conversation where you're doing that, and I'm, like, that's totally cool, right?
I mean, you know, I mean, I'm doing it, too, and then, you know, we pull back at various levels.
I mean, that's what's cool.
When I was talking about the diagramming thing, a lot of it is the sort of investment dynamics, like, sort of putting forward and pulling back, but also in which direction.
Like, I do have this kind of fractal image in my head of that first conversation that was going to be my diagram, but a lot of it does.
It is, like, one of us is pushing forward, and how do the other two respond when that happens?
Sometimes it's following.
Sometimes it's kind of redirecting, you know, and, but that's the thing that's interesting to me in the process of how the three of us think together, you know?
That's what I've really liked, and I was going to say, it doesn't, what I'm really enjoying about this is it doesn't really matter to me what direction you take, Nate.
I like that you're taking a specific direction because it's a chance for me to practice kind of following and contending.
Because I, I mean, the reality is, it's usually when I'm doing something like this, I'm the one that's kind of, I'm often the one that's kind of channeling my own project through things.
And it's really nice for me to not be doing that.
It just allows, it allows me to practice a kind of agility.
So, like, don't feel like you need to create space for me, at least, because I'm enjoying the, being put in the more responsive position.
And that, you know, I'm sure that'll change, but.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
I'll still, I'll keep pushing the Malibu Jameson.
Do it, man.
Do it.
No, you should, you really should.
I mean, you know, and like, I feel like I'm, I don't know that I feel like I'm pushing the Deleuze thing.
There's always these reminders of this, you know, a kind of Deleuzian insistence on affirmation.
And it's not distinction, but it's, it's not, it's relation or non-relation to negation.
You know, and obviously I, I track back and forth on it.
And it's, I, I just feel like if anything, my comments have been just this mirroring of self-conscious reflection.
Like, I feel like that's constantly what I'm doing.
Like, well, I think this, but I recognize that in thinking this, I am in fact doing the thing that Hegel is mapping out.
And then I recognize that in thinking that, that I'm thinking this, that I'm, you know, I mean, I, I felt like I have been doing the kind of textbook Hegelian more than both of you guys.
Right.
Like I have just, I have been, no matter what we're saying, I'm doing the moves that Hegel is outlining like really explicitly, which I just.
Until you find yourself in a closet unable to act at all.
You're about 15 meta layers deep.
Right.
Hey man, meta is better.
You stare at the abyss, you stare at the abyss long enough and it stares back at you.
The abyss stares back into you, man.
I don't find it to be, are you using that terminology last time?
And just because you mentioned before, and obviously it's an issue, I don't find an abyss here, right?
I don't, I don't feel like the sort of that absolute contingency is anything like an abyss.
It's, it actually seems much more just pure responsiveness, you know?
I mean, so it doesn't feel like there's a vacuous or nothingness, you know?
I mean, that's actually sort of, I mean, there's a philosophical argument there too, because he does seem to like the idea of absence or lack or space or whatever as the sort of what enables movement.
And certainly Butler does.
But I don't think you need it.
Like, you don't have to have something missing in order to have space to move.
But that's, I mean, we're going to get into that actually in the chunks that we talk about today too.
Well, yeah.
I mean, it's like the dialectic between unity and dissolution.
It's like you, at least for Hegel, I think you do need those, those terms.
Like, if subjectivity is pure negation, then it's a void.
It is an abyss.
I mean, because everything completely gets, falls apart under the, the specter of this thing.
You know, it's, it has to be an abyss for me, right?
I mean, because of the figure of unity is so, is still persistent, the figure of totality, the opposite, the abyss of the void has to also be present.
See, I mean, I continually think that the abyss and the totality are not different at all.
That totality is, is the abyss.
And, you know, especially in the last sections of, I think maybe it was 13, but we're talking about the self-consciousness of some paradigm.
Is that seem to actually be the, the, the, both the fulfillment and the destruction of the paradigm as a moment where the paradigm becomes conscious unto itself,
which stops the movement or creates the conditions of necessity for a new kind of movement to emerge.
So the, I mean, you know, I, I have a feeling that this is going to get tweaked in the next several paragraphs,
but that's at least just reading that paragraph.
It seemed to me that the abyss and negation was in no way at all opposed to, um, the, the, the fulfillment of a, um, of a paradigm's limit.
Yeah.
And there's, there's several, there's obviously also several types of abysses and voids.
And I think in 16, did we end at 16?
I don't remember, but, um, he, it's still kind of, I think it's still, uh, critiquing Spinoza here or some of those figures.
And their abyss is the one that he's saying is basically wrong.
The void of that monism is a naive response, I think, to the empirical mindset.
So we, we don't have to dive into that just yet, but, but they're like, when you, when you actually, um, when you make the opposition and reify each term,
which I think what is, what he's critiquing, like that's choosing either side of those, the empiricist mindset or the kind of monist affective one.
Both of those are wrong for Hegel.
Um, cause they don't incorporate the, the, all the valences of the dialectic.
But that, but that, I mean, I guess that's why I don't think of it as an abyss.
And maybe I'm not thinking very, uh, precisely about, I mean, when you said different kinds of abysses, um, but to me, if what we're talking about is, okay, you've got a assertion of any kind, you have then the self-conscious realization of, let's say, the motivation behind the assertion.
Then you have the self-conscious recognition of the self-conscious awareness, uh, of, of the assertion.
What you get to in building up there is never nothing.
You just get to responsiveness, right?
Like you're always responding to the previous moment.
And so when I think of like building that up, you get to, to me, what's something that you would call kind of pure responsiveness, you know, without the statement or utterance anymore.
But pure responsiveness doesn't seem empty to me.
It seems like super fucking crazy ass active, like, um, you know, like relentlessly, constantly.
I mean, responsiveness is always a response to, to some, to something, right?
Like to some, even if it's not a statement or an utterance or whatever, even if it's a response to responsiveness.
Like I don't find self-consciousness when I think, when I'm sort of my experience thinking through it, I don't find self-consciousness to loop me into a neurotic, uh, um, sort of stagnant, you know, space.
I actually find it constantly sort of transformative, you know, if I'm, so if I'm self-conscious of the statement I just made and then I become self-conscious of my self-consciousness,
I don't find that paralyzing the way that people often talk about is like, well, if you just become self-conscious, then you're just thinking about your own thinking.
And I'm like, well, thinking about my own thinking is really fun, right?
I mean, I find that really interesting, and I never find it to be a dead end.
I always find it to be like, in each moment I find that I'm discovering something else about my thinking, and it never just gets to this like, oh, I can't act anymore.
I've just never, I never feel, I don't know.
I mean, I guess I have an intuition of what that means and why people think that, but I don't think, you know, my argument for self-consciousness, the reason, like, I actually quite agree with Hegel that, you know, the self-conscious, some becoming conscious of itself and then it's, then the becoming conscious of oneself, like, I just think that's fun, right?
That's just a more interesting, I don't think it's a better way to live.
I don't think it's a, it allows you any heightened purchase on anything.
I just think that I'm interested enough in thinking and the movement of concepts or thinking that it's this constant, I mean, I can now swim for 40 minutes and all I'm doing while I'm swimming is, is these sort of self-conscious reflections.
And I, and the time goes by like that because it's interesting to me, you know.
I think the, the negative connotation at least needs to be held a little bit at bay with the abyss because the abyss is generative.
Like you're saying, I think the idea of response though, that you're talking about is exactly what he's saying, but it's the destructive cast capacity of the response that, uh, not leads to, but like is kind of brought or engendered out of that abyss.
And it's the fact that, you know, for Hegel madness is kind of primary.
It's the, it's the, you know, uh, the capacity or the tendency or what, what's the word, the potential to like lead into that moment of neurosis that actually, uh, allows for further moments of self-consciousness.
It's kind of like, it's, it's like a more advanced version of Descartes, uh, you know, madness is, yeah, madness is primary for Descartes.
And then you, you kind of advance past it with the self-transparency of the subject for Hegel.
It's like, I mean, I can't really articulate it right now, but it's a more sophisticated, like, uh, progression from out of madness into, into reason or self-consciousness.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, it might be, it, yeah, I get, I get where for other people, like, you know, like the, the constant meta move, I was having a text exchange with Hunter Nathaniel, uh, earlier and she had just read my PNR piece and she's like, Ooh, it's interesting because you posit the sort of meta move as a way out from kind of anger.
And it's true. That's in fact what that piece does. And, uh, but we were just sort of went back and forth and I was just like, look, I just like living in the meta move. It's just a more interesting place to live.
And it's just sort of where I live too. It's not, you know, it's not, I don't think it's better for anyone else. I think it's just kind of what I do, but, but you know, her, she's like, yeah, I can, you know, it would get a little crazy, you know, for her, she's like, it would just get crazy to have to be so constant.
And I'm like, I don't find that it gets crazy, but I understand at some level, I understand why people would think that, but it's never been my experience.
I think that there's a, I think there's a presumption. I mean, I've just been thinking about it since you started bringing it up because I never think of that beyond the sort of commonplaces, but there's a duality between thought and action at play that governs that commonplace.
It's like paralysis is only paralysis if, you know, the, the, the subject of the original thought is the only thing that is real.
And then everything else is nothing but mental capacity.
So you, so if the entire movement is intensive and upward and only meta, then the action never, ever changes, right?
And that's the paralysis.
But as soon as you problematize that binary, I think you say like every single, every single iteration of the thinking, even if it's what we would commonplace,
like common sensically call thinking is no less.
No, I think that's, I think that's dead on because if you presume that the purpose of thinking is to tell you what to do in the world of action,
then yeah, I can see how, you know, you like, well, too much meta reflection means that you just don't make a decision, right?
But, but, but if you think of thinking as just its own kind of action, uh, that is on an action or whatever, yeah, then, then it doesn't have that, you don't face that kind of, it's not meta, right?
It's just differentiation.
I mean, we can call it meta and I understand why she does and why people, I mean, for instance, when I wrote that, that P and R, I don't know, you read that Nathaniel, right?
Like, yeah.
So when I wrote that thing, I never thought of it as meta at all.
It just never occurred to me.
I certainly see how.
I didn't either.
Right.
But I see it.
It was just like, oh, here's another thing to do rather than get really pissed off is think, right?
And that's, I swear, that's it for me was I'm really fucking pissed.
I'm really fucking pissed.
It's so many different sort of external cultural and political things and I'm not cool with that and it's banal and so I want to figure out something else.
And so thinking becomes a way of doing that for me.
So it's an action.
It's kind of like so is swimming.
Swimming becomes or whatever, you know, making your music, Nate, or whatever, you know, family time for Nathaniel.
Sorry, I just had to laugh on that one.
But whatever it is that sort of pulls you out of that because to me it's the anger and rage, the resentment is much closer to something like a fucking paralyzing abyss for me.
Well, it's the response or the reaction to what's basically a primary estrangement or alienation.
Like, so I know that we're all hesitant, you know, probably for good reasons about the historical trajectory or the telos, even some of the evolutionary stuff in Hegel.
But basically what he starts, you know, if you look at the progression of humanity, it starts in a version of animality, right?
Where it's just immediate relation to the world, sense certainty, we're not yet thrown into language or the symbolic.
Once you're thrown into language post, like, tribal colonies, you know, once you actually have civilization, that's then primary.
There's no getting out of that.
That's a primary estrangement or alienation.
And then the reactions to that then, that's what frames your orientation towards the world or towards discourse.
So, like, we talk about the empiricist mindset, the rationalism kind of paradigm.
These are all responses to a primary alienation.
And then the one that he's endorsing, which you're talking about, John, is the kind of reflexive self-consciousness where you're what you're constantly aware of that process of estrangement and alienation.
And you're just, you're turning it over again and again, seeing what it does for thinking, for, you know, how you behave in the world.
Yeah.
I just, I just bristle at the terminology, the thinking of alienation, estrangement, right?
Like, because to me it's just, I mean, just at a kind of baseline level, I'm like, no, just things approach me.
Things come in.
Like, that's where the thinking, for me, the thinking of multiplicity is, like, things pop into, you know, my horizon of awareness or whatever.
And they become spurs for thinking.
So, it's not, well, but let's, I mean, maybe we should.
You still have to deal with the multiplicity.
This is why, I just don't see that much of a difference conceptually or affectively.
Like, dealing with estrangement versus dealing with multiplicity, it's like both are kind of scary, right?
Both are, like, kind of disorienting and you still have to reckon with those things.
I don't, see, but I mean, I understand what you're saying, but I don't feel, uh, the thinking of alienation, which presumes a unity that is dissociated, whereas to me the thinking of multiplicity, again, I agree that it's not reassuring or comforting.
But I don't find it scary because the multiplicity includes me and my consciousness, too.
So, it's just a series of, like, that's where the sort of Deleuze-Nietzschean line of forces, you know, you just, it's a multiplicity of, you know, wills, really, in the Nietzsche, the traditional Nietzsche language.
It's just a multiplicity of wills encountering different multiplicities of wills.
But there's always a familiarity, as well, in that, you know, the thing we call John is 17 different sort of competing wills, and it encounters something else that has a different 25 things, but three of them are familiar, you know what I mean?
So, there's, there's always some, some resonance of some kind, and so it's, uh, it's, it's not me, maybe, but it's, it's also not simply other.
I don't begin from that premise, I guess.
Yeah.
Um, it's more just like, oh, there's cool things in the world, and look, some of those cool things can kill you, right?
I mean, or the things that seem like the cool things in the world, like, you know, my caveman Nietzsche story, right?
Like, those, those interesting, fascinating things might just cut you in half, you know?
Well, right, well, here's, like, just to, I mean, so, Hegel obviously kind of starts from the premise of subjectivity or self-consciousness, whereas someone like Deleuze starts with force.
Um, the thing is, Hegel's, the, the supposition about the activity of self, of, of subjectivity or self-consciousness is that its goal, regardless of what your intentions are, is to assimilate, and, and so it's, it's basic, it's basic impulse is fascistic.
Now, the, it never reaches that goal, it never fully assimilates in its environment, but that's the premise, is that subjectivity is trying to assimilate its environment in, in, in order to, I don't know, resonate or,
or, or somehow find, uh, temporary comfort or solace there.
So, if that's where subjectivity starts, um, then you could almost even incorporate multiplicity, right?
It's like you can't critique Hegel.
You could, you could incorporate multiplicity as a reaction to the mechanism of self-consciousness.
You know, so, but the versions of, the versions of multiplicity end up being very different, right?
Because multiplicity is generated through self-alienation as opposed to a sort of prima facie, uh,
Yeah, yeah, ontologically primary, right?
Like, ontologically primary is the, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so, I mean, that, this is, this is, what I arrived at in the little thing that I wrote on Hegel is, like,
I mean, among, among other questions that I wrote out is just,
is the whole multiplicity or unity thing, is it, um, is it just a stylistic question?
And I don't mean just in that sense, John, but, like, is it...
Fuck you guys and you're just stylists.
I think, but I want, I want to really think about the gravitational force of, like,
what's the pull of unity versus multiplicity and, you know, big speed?
Yeah.
The big speed want to focus on those passages because it seems that as soon as you start with unity,
you are tied into a very, very specific trajectory.
And if you start with multiplicity, then there are an infinite, literally a different,
an infinite number of trajectories that are, none of which are mutually exclusive.
And, um, and that second one, just at an intuitive level, just seems like the case,
but I want to interrogate that intuition.
And so, for instance, the appropriation dynamics that you're talking about, and obviously we're
going to get to it in this paragraph, but, um, uh, another word for that, for the, you know,
sort of appropriation of Heibung relation is will to power.
And the, the thing that I like about will to power as a Nietzschean concept is because,
at least to me, who's been reading a lot of, you know, Nietzsche for a very long time,
will to power itself has its vacillation, which is to say it is on the one hand, the will to possess power,
which is the conventional reading and understanding.
It is also very clearly in places for Nietzsche, not about appropriation, but about enactment, right?
So, so that difference is built into the concept.
I won't say built into the concept because nothing is, but it, it has, even in Nietzsche,
it has that, you know, that dual sensibility of sort of incorporation and ex-corporation,
you know, it, it, it's there.
And that, that's why I like will to power because the, the sort of appropriation of Heibung,
subsequent appropriation, although, you know, we're going to have to get into the little,
like, because importantly in the Heibung, you don't dissolve the differences, right?
Like you both maintain and, or you both sublate and maintain them.
So the differences between the positions still exists in the, in the meta sort of increased
self-consciousness realm.
So it's been overcome and maintain, you know, so, so it really is trying to do a similar thing
as, as will to power in that regard.
You know, it's not simply appropriation of like, this is now mine and I own it.
It's like, well, it's still different, right?
It still maintains its difference.
But so the mechanism would have to, oh, go for it.
Just, I mean, the, one of the main differences, it seems like in a really simple language is
just that there is action for Nietzsche after reaction.
So once you get past, uh, kind of the dynamics of Resentiment, then there's the potential
for acts, for active like response in the world.
For Hegel, it's only reaction.
There's no, there's literally no way to posit that active principle in the Hegelian system.
Right.
Yeah.
I, I agree, but I would also say that Deleuze's version of Nietzsche, it's equivocal on this
one, but, you know, my reading on this is there, you know, I've been saying this, Nathaniel's
heard this too many times, but like there literally is no such thing as active force, right?
Like, cause insofar as it's not a thing.
Now it's still a force in action and relational, but it's not a force, strictly speaking, because
in order for it to be a force, it has to be recognized, identified.
It's, it, it is, reactive force is all there is.
And it's a question of different things that one does with reactive force, but.
I would even go further and say that there is no such thing as reactive force as well,
because it's, it's still in action with, there is only, I mean, you know, one, active force
Is never, can never be disassociated from reactive force because the, any activity is, it always
produces reactions, right?
And two, like, reactive forces, again, aren't things that preexist the activity that bring
them about, like, like, reactive force is always, only ever the singular response to its act of
appropriation.
And then, then you, and then if you're going to talk about anything beyond that, it's like
the residue of that reactivity that you would say is in, in any conventional sense of the
term.
Yeah, we can go back and read that chapter, that last chapter, that against Hegelianism chapter,
you know, in, in Duluth.
I mean, I know we did it a month ago or so, but it might be worthwhile after we do this and
Nietzsche and Zizek and, you know, those kinds of things to go back and, and revisit it.
And I, I think, but what, go ahead, the, what I was going to say earlier is, is that, you know,
appropriation, uh, in, in the Hegelian sense, as far as I understand it is, it, it's not, you
know, it's not the vulgar appropriation of it's, it's now mine, but, you know, it's generative
in so far as there has to be a first as a self alienation, which is, that's generative itself.
Just to be able to say this thing that I do not recognize as me is really only the product,
of me, a self alienation of me.
And then this thing that has been self alienated gets appropriated and retaken in and transforms
both.
Right?
Like that, one, that's wild.
Like that's, that's fascinatingly interesting and wild, but it like otherness has to be produced
as a by-product of the same.
And so the, the, the, the self-differentiation is really interesting.
But what you don't get are, is it any kind of heterogeneity, right?
Like you only ever get to the two.
It's only ever the, the two becomes the one becomes the two becomes the one.
Right.
Whereas, you know, like you said, there are 17 different wills that have taken up John
and encounters another thing that have had 25 different, you know, I mean, there you get
a different kind of heterogeneity there where it's, it's not just, you know, one force on
another force, but it's one force on another force that produces one kind of reaction.
And then that as a subset has another force that can take a hold of it and produce different
kinds of reactions.
And you just get like an infinite set of, I mean, like the interplay is just infinite.
That's honestly, that's honestly the appeal for me is, is this feels, I mean, the underlying,
it's a tone question, but this feels just monologic, you know.
But like, I don't, you're right, you're both, you're right.
But the, the, those 17 different wills or however many Nietzsche articulates, it's not
that those are incompatible with Hegel's system, it's just that they're, it's, they're
incorporated under a formal tendency, which is reaction, reaction to contingency.
So like, the, the, the basic philosophical tendency to aim for meta reflection or metacognition
where you're thinking about your own thinking or thinking about the world, et cetera, that's,
that's kind of the, you know, the standard rationalist approach.
When you get to Hegel, you know, it becomes something very different where you're actually
reflecting on the impossibility of metacognition or meta reflection.
And so the shape of thinking takes all these stranger turns, but it's still, it's still a
reaction to the contingency of thought and of thinking.
So it's like, there's still no, there's, even though unity is a figure, there's no unifying
mechanism here.
It's, it's all basically, um, a dissonant orientation towards contingency for me.
You know what I mean?
I don't, like, I don't know.
I had, I had a, I had like a synthesis of that point in my head and I lost it, but.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
But that's good.
I mean, it's good.
And I do take, I do take that point.
I think that you're quite right.
The 1725 is, is subsumable in the Hegelian thinking.
Um, but it's the fact of it's being subsumable.
I mean, that's where, you know, again, I, I, I, my, my baseline intuition is to say the
difference between the two.
I mean, as Nathaniel said, it's the one and the two, the one and the two, and that kind
of monotonous monologism that generates endlessly like proliferative differences.
It, it just feels to me, I mean, I would say it this way, there's a, there's, it's not
an accident that Hegel thinks of the negative as laborious, hard, cold, right?
And it, it's also not an accident that Nietzsche thinks of multiplicity as joyful, dancing, laughing,
you know?
So that, that, those aren't, those aren't accidental predicates, um, that they have just happened
to associate with them.
And, and, and, and that's where, again, I mean, I, I mean, I said this, you know, a few
things ago, but it's like, it, it kind of does seem to me to kind of come down to, I mean,
I don't think at the level of the proposition, I think that you can do everything in the Hegelian
system that Nietzsche does, right?
Or, or vice versa.
And, and I really do think that the, the dispositional preference comes down to, you know, like the,
the affective draw of the relentless sort of hard ass-ness or the affective draw of like
play, play, right?
Um, but here's, here's one way that you can't say that, John, is that if you're Hegelian,
like, it's very easy from the Deleuzian perspective to say that like Hegelianism can do its thing
and it's one aspect, it's a total, it's a totalitizing impulse or alliance within the multiplicity and
it gathers stuff to it and it does everything that it says that it is, but it's one thread
and it'll rise and fall or, you know, whatever.
Um, but from the Hegelian perspective, you know, multiplicity has to be a moment or a phase
within a bigger picture.
And so you can articulate the exact same propositions, but I, this is where I would say it's, this is
not just a style thing, not, not merely, but like in addition to a stylistic thing, it,
it's, ends up being very necessary as well that, you know, it's one is a species of the
other or the other is a species of the one.
And I, that's, that's what I want to really try to, to think through because you are, because
I think the, um, I think that your emphasis on, on style presumes the, the, the Deleuzian
perspective, like you don't get that perspective from the Hegelian perspective.
You don't get, that's not an option.
I don't think.
No, I think that's fair.
I think that's fair.
The, the only, the danger for me, and it's not even really associated with Deleuze, um,
but with sort of more vulgar versions of that, where it's like a, like Barad, I would say,
where it's kind of a stricter, uh, empiricism is that the tendency is to think that you've
gotten outside of the movement of negation.
And that's the desire.
We, we don't want to be negating.
It's like, why, why do we have to be doing that anymore?
But even when you're getting to this point where, so let's say you're foregrounding the
impossibility of assimilation.
So that's kind of what self-consciousness does.
Like what you're talking about, John, you're constantly folding back on your own positions
and seeing like, you know, so why am I doing this?
Why am I thinking that?
And then you keep coming back and like interrogating that process.
That's still, still for Hegel a process, a process of assimilation.
Foregrounding the impossibility of assimilation is a process of assimilation.
Right.
So it's like, even when we think like, when we think we're getting outside of that Hegelian
impulse or that, that process of reaction, negation, uh, deflecting contingency, it all,
it just comes back to that movement once you, you keep kind of, uh, reflecting on it.
But again, that, that movement is interpreted in at least one of two ways because either it's
the perpetual failure to get to the pure meta-reflective state.
Even if that meta-reflective state is the pure position where you can hold the inability to
obtain that meta-reflective state.
Right.
Or it's just perpetuating encounters between difference because the, because it produces
stuff that's interesting.
Right.
And again, it can be the, like from the outside or the inside of it, it seems like it'd be impossible
to tell the difference by the, it's, it's also the most essential difference between the
two.
And so far as we can talk about essences with things.
That's good.
I like that, man.
We gotta, we gotta highlight that point.
That'll be the thesis, the thesis for today's, that was good.
That was, that was helpful.
So we have successfully, as we always do, burned the first hour on just talking.
So now let's turn to chapter 17 because that can give us a kind of, or paragraph 17 because
17 and 18, right, is when we get into the, the beginning of the meat of his thing.
Do you want me to read this one?
John, we, or John.
We're closer to, to sentence 17 than we are chapter 17.
It's true.
Actually.
Okay.
17.
In my view, which can be justified only by the exposition of the system itself, everything
turns on grasping and expressing the true, not only as substance, but equally as subject.
At the same time, as if that's self-explanatory, like I, I don't really need to explain what
I mean by that.
So I'm just going to say.
Next hour on this sentence.
Right.
Everything depends on grasping and expressing the true, not only as substance, but equally
as subject.
The other thing, at the same time, it is to be observed that substantiality embraces the
universal or the immediacy of knowledge itself, as well as that which is being or immediacy
for knowledge.
If a conception of God as the one substance shocked the age in which it was proclaimed,
the reason for this was on the one hand, an instinctive awareness that in this definition,
self-consciousness was only submerged and not preserved.
On the other hand, the opposite view, which clings to thought as thought, to universality as
such, is the very same simplicity is undifferentiated, unmoved substantiality.
And if, thirdly, thought does unite itself with the being of substance and apprehends immediacy
or intuitionist thinking, the question is still whether this intellectual intuition does not
again fall back into inert simplicity and does not depict actuality itself in a non-actual
manner.
That first sentence to me is really only reflecting on the last couple of paragraphs about, you
know, the replace the true there for a second with the notion, the simplicity of a notion.
And then everything, you know, everything turns on grasping the expression of that notion into
its fullest externality, right?
Which means that not only does it describe the world according to its logic, but it also
produces the self-awareness, the commonplace, intuitive self-awareness necessary to understand
the world as it has been remade.
So again, it's not just, you know, re-describing the world in Newtonian terms, but it is the
commonplaceness of just being the Newtonian subject.
Like, I am a body that is moved by forces, right?
That to me is what's going on there.
It is the illusion between substance and subject where whatever notion has just so thoroughly
interpreted its world that subject and substance become effectively the same thing.
But it cannot do it, and, you know, perhaps, like, maybe the last movement of spirit, which
is itself impossible, would be the pure illusion of those two things without remade here, but
there's got to be remade here.
There has to, it has to, this thing has to wear itself out, it has to become tired, and
it has to produce the necessity for the new self-alienated notion.
Well, so, I mean, I'm going to start with a simpler question, which is, what does he mean
by substance and subject here?
And for me, there are two kind of, I mean, not distinct things, but there are two emphases.
The emphasis on subject, or on substance, let's start with substance first, right?
Substance on the one hand just means objects, right?
Things, stuff, right?
Whatever.
To that extent, subject means self-knowing, right?
Like, or having knowledge.
What distinguishes subject from substance is knowledge, right?
Awareness, cognition, whatever.
So that's the traditional subject-object split.
Right.
It also seems to me, or maybe even more importantly, that here the emphasis is not really that so
much as inert versus active, right?
That inert or static versus active being the key differences.
Now, of course, one can get that from cognition versus stuff, you know, but the thing that I,
my sense that he's calling attention to is expressing the true not only as substance, meaning something
that's there, right, but also as subject, which is something that is acting.
So it's, you know, being becoming, right?
It is, and that's what I'm saying, like, that, that, those to me are somewhat different
emphases than subject-object, sort of separation, alienation between me and the world.
And then the second part being, because even in that subject-object, object stuff could be
moving, can be active, right?
But versus this active versus inert.
So, I mean, the truth needs to be grasped not just as something that is statically there,
but as something that is enacted.
And that's where, you know, it's a philosophy of becoming, but it is also a philosophy of
being that substance has to be, you know, has to equal subject.
So when you say, if the conception of God as the one substance shocked the age in which
it was proclaimed, the reason for this was on the one hand, an instinctive awareness
that in the, in this definition, self-consciousness was only submerged and not preserved.
Now, I don't quite get that, right?
I don't quite get, because that's, I think, is Spinoza, right?
God as the one, as the one substance.
What was shocking was that self-consciousness seemed to be irrelevant, right?
If God is the one substance, then the fact of our awareness of anything just is a manifestation
of God like any other manifestation of God.
And it doesn't have any heightened or privileged sort of relationship to, to stuff.
So, right, that's my, that's my, that's my read.
If, if God is immanent in Spinoza, then subjectivity is kind of an arbitrary byproduct.
It's, it has nothing to do with the system.
It's one inessential effect of, of that, uh, that God term.
It might be useful to think about the, the shifting targets here in this paragraph, because I think
you're right, that part's Spinoza, but then you mentioned Schelling, I think, on Monday, and
I think that's maybe what he's moving to when he's talking about the opposite view.
So, which clings to, clings to thought as thought.
On the other hand, clings to thought as thought, universality as such.
Right.
And that's still an undifferentiated, unmoved substantiality.
So, these are like all, like you're saying, this is a philosophy of becoming, it's also a
philosophy of the impossibility of thinking becoming proper, at least until we get to Hegel.
It's like, he's constantly saying, like, we, we think we're thinking becoming, but this
is just motionless, inert simplicity.
And we don't get the endorsement of his own thing here.
It's just like, well, maybe we're still not doing this.
It's like, even at the end of the paragraph, even when we think, like, when we get to the
point where like, oh, this sounds like Hegel, that sounds like the good thing.
Nope, that's still bad.
Right.
You know?
So, if it does, because, so if thought unites with, so on, you know,
you've got your pretty straightforward synthesis, antithesis, you know, or rather, you know,
Statement, antithesis, synthesis move here, right?
And you're, I mean, you're right.
He's like, okay, so the first thought is, God is substance.
That's everything.
That renders thought and self-consciousness to just be a epiphenomenal manifestation of
this prior thing.
On the other hand, you have thought being primary.
It clings to thought.
That's universality as such.
This is unmoved substantiality.
So, substance just becomes stuff that you know, right?
Like, it just becomes this irrelevant, again, secondary, just like the first one was, you know,
the second one.
So, but in third, if thought does unite with the being of substance and apprehends immediacy
or intuition as thinking, the question is still whether this intellectual intuition does
not fall back into inert simplicity and doesn't depict actuality itself in a non-actual manner.
I mean, that's kind of a hedge.
Like, he doesn't really say anything in that third one other than to say the usual ways
of attempting to synthesize, you know, thought and stuff is, are, may not be adequate.
The simple fact of proclaiming a synthesis might just be like, again, it would be another
way to say, remember what I said the other day about, like, my dissatisfaction with both
and, right?
It's like, this is a both and move, right?
That he's saying the both and move maintains both and, and it doesn't do anything other than
that.
Well, this is the, um, uh, in some ways I see him as asking that same question that I
was asking is the, are there dead ends?
And in this thirdly section, it seems like it's like, look, if you make that both and move,
if you made it, make the simple synthesis move, then, then you get to an inert simplicity.
And I mean, I'm going to guess that it's not going to hold very long, but it's, I think
it's just the, the sort of the, the Aufhebung has to be, has to be more than that.
It has to be more than just synthesis.
It has to be more than just the both and.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And the, both Schelling, if, if, you know, I'm just speculating if he's talking about him
there with that second critique, both Schelling and Spinoza are clinging to different versions
of immediacy.
For Spinoza, it's, it's God is eminence.
For Schelling, I think it's subjectivity is sort of the, the operative term.
And even when you try to do a simple synthesis of those two, which could be kind of like
a vulgar Hegelianism, that's still a version of that, you know, grasping for something,
grasping for reality, for the thing in itself.
Whereas for Hegel, that's, that's utterly impossible.
I mean, I, yeah, I mean, I, I agree with you.
Like, I agree, I mean, here's what I agree with.
I feel like he's laying out, again, what we would look at and call, most people would
say, well, that's a dialectic, thesis, antithesis, synthesis.
He's got three possible positions, right?
Mm-hmm.
And, you know, one is substance, one is subject, and one is an attempt to wed, to wed the two.
If nothing else, what we can say is, one of the things that he's pointing out is that
there, there's more than one Aufhebung, there's more than one way to Aufhebung in the dialectic.
I thought that was more clever than it is.
But, but, you know, so, so he's not, he's, you know, if anything, saying, I'm not the
first to discover the synthetic move, but I'm the first to really try and make it, you know,
to take it seriously and, and to insist upon, again, for me, the active, you have to maintain
the active and object status, so the, you have to think as active and stuff as not simply
inert, right?
So you have to sort of do both of those things, so.
Right, I mean, that, that.
But this, I mean, it shows, like, the, the, the easy idea about, you, whatever, proposition
and that, how does it go, proposition, something else, and then synthesis, or I forget the.
Antithesis.
Yeah, yeah.
Thesis, antithesis, synthesis.
Like, this paragraph just shows you basically the impossibility of that, at least of no easy
synthesis, because the hedging in that, right at the end, it's like, well, okay, well then,
none, none of this, there's no satisfying answer to this problem yet, right?
Well, it, it seems more like the satisfying answer is the dangerous answer, the one that
renders the thing inert and stops the movement of thinking, that the synthesis, that is nothing
more than the, like, one plus two equals, if, if, if, if it's the equality of the one plus
two to the three, then that's the inert simplicity of the idea that doesn't self-alienate and generate,
you know, a new opportunity for appropriation, it doesn't remake anything, there is no.
Right, right.
It still, it still feels more formal, though, like, or rather, the thing, in talking through
it, I'm still unclear, other than at the formal level, of what the third synthesis looks like,
or the, the third move, the synthetic move, like, if, thirdly, thought does unite itself
with the being of substance, and apprehends immediacy or intuition as thinking, right?
So, I mean.
You know what?
I'm thinking, sorry, just, that might be a critique of Kant kind of right in there, because
Kant would usually be sort of the post-empiricist, post-rationalist person, but even, even Kant,
I think, for Hegel doesn't take it far enough.
So, he would be the one to think intuition as thinking, where there's basically, there's
no, if immediacy is mediation, right, there is no actual immediacy for Kant.
For Spinoza and Schelling, there is still, they're still clinging to a version of immediacy.
Right.
So, Kant is doing that synthesis move, that third position.
I still don't really know how, or I can't articulate how Hegel's going to differentiate himself from
that, but that might be the, the unnamed target there.
Okay.
But at the moment, at the moment, I mean, like, you know, subtract Spinoza, Schelling,
and Kant from it, and, you know, just imagine some, you know, playing signifier there, you know,
as, as the specific target, just at the level of system, he just seems to be posing the question,
like, the, this third move is not, you have to, you have to take it seriously, that it runs
the risk of becoming nothing more than any, than a, than a vulgar synthesis, and this is
something that, he's just saying, we have to pay attention to this as we move forward.
Right.
Right?
That this is a pitfall.
It's the right path, but you have, if you don't do it right, you're going to screw it
up.
This comes back to one of the initial points before we started reading, for me, the, the
impossibility of getting past the movement of negation, or the compulsion toward, like,
of reifying the movement of negation.
Like, this all, this all, to me, could work as a critique of resentment in the Nietzschean
vein, this whole paragraph, at least in the, in a philosophical sense, where you are negating
the world, you know, you're, you're denying the, the force of life, and you're also forgetting
that you're doing that.
Like, you're, you don't even realize that you're doing that in some of these conceptual
moves.
I mean, insofar as the fear here is, I think, I think some kind of stalling of the machine,
which would be, if that, the effect of stalling a form of life, I, I agree.
I just, I want to unpack that, I mean, you know, unpack that, but I, I, I would say,
let's, let's go on now.
Let's go on, let's do 18 too, um, just because it's, I mean, it's pretty, yeah, it's clearly
a development of 17 and it matters in this context.
So, um, someone else, someone else do their thing.
I can do it.
It's the different translation though, but, um, okay.
Furthermore, the living substance is the being that is in truth subject, or what amounts
to the same thing.
It is in truth actual only insofar as it is the movement of self-positing, or that it is
the mediation of itself and its becoming other to itself.
As subject, it is pure, simple negativity, and as a result, it is the estrangement of what
is simple, or it is the doubling which posits oppositions and which is again the negation
of this indifferent diversity and its opposition.
That is, it is only this self-restoring sameness, the reflective turn into itself in its otherness.
The true is not an original unity as such, or not an immediate unity as such.
It is the coming to be of itself, the circle that presupposes its end as its goal and has
its end for its beginning, and which is actual only through its accomplishment and its end.
Yeah, I mean, that's one of those paragraphs where I feel like you could literally just
read that indefinitely, right?
Yeah, that's the one.
That's the one, yeah.
Um.
Oh, man, yeah.
But this is just about the necessity of, um, self-alienation to the continued movement.
Right.
And it's like, look, don't, this isn't, don't, don't, don't read the, um, the opposition
between subject and substance as a, like a vulgar exterior, um, uh, opposition.
But this is a self-alienation and this sort of specific quality of this opposition is a self-relating
and that it is this movement that, I mean, this is, it, this is becoming, right?
Negation as the mechanism of, of becoming.
The self-restoring sameness or this reflection in otherness within itself, not an original
or immediate unity as such.
So not two independent things that become the same thing, but a single thing that expresses
its difference and then reappropriates it into the whole thing changes.
Yeah, and this is, uh, this is sort of one of Malibu's points, too, is that human nature
is always a second nature.
There's no, if, if mediation is the thing in itself, right, there's no immediate unity
as such, then human being is always in that, uh, mediative, uh, position.
There's no access to the world in itself.
There's no immediate, uh, unity.
There's no affective, uh, there's no easy way out, uh, of this movement of negation, um,
for Malibu, for her reading.
And it sort of seems to come through here in this paragraph a little bit.
And, I mean, not to just bulldoze through it, but the, the, all, the, all, the idea of
the beginning and end, right, at the end of this paragraph, it's like, you can't get an
easy idea of telos out of that.
I mean, that's where all of the easy ideas of progress or evolution are like, what, where
do you get that here?
When the result is the beginning.
Yeah.
But, but even if, I mean, even if you can subtract telos, what you clearly have is development.
Like, there's a difference between simplicity one and simplicity two and simplicity three
and simplicity four and the, the latter, no, the latter ones are more true, right?
Like they are, so simplicity one, you know, is less true.
But the development, the development is not from an origin.
If you can think of development without origin somehow.
Yeah.
But that, that's relatively easy to do.
I think, but you still, I think there are still two, I agree that kind of telos, I think
is absent for me here.
But I think there are two other kinds of telos that are happening at two different levels.
The first one is the one I think that we're talking about more immediately here, which
is the positing of the, the, the notion or the simplicity posited, posits its own end,
deposits its own telos, right?
And then, you know, but its end isn't equal to its telos.
It has to go through the work of doing this thing, but it posits its own telos and works
toward it, right?
And it's precisely the working toward that end and the failure of doing it, you could say
that brings about the next simplicity, which posits a new and different end, which then
exteriorizes itself toward that, that end.
So that's the level of telos that we're talking about here.
And, and, and if we were just talking about that notion of telos, I, I would agree with
you that, I mean, as long as we also said then that, um, you know, it's not just a matter
of failing that telos, but it can go any number of different directions.
But let's just pause that for a second, because I think there's still another level of telos
operating here at the, because this telos is imminent, right?
This telos is imminently expressed and then realized.
But there's the other telos at the transcendent level that I think John was trying to articulate,
which is, and this simplicity, you know, posits its own telos and expresses itself and demands
a new, um, simplicity, which posits its own telos.
And this one's, the second one's better than the first one.
The second one's more self-aware or more aligned with, um, absolute spirit than, than the first
one.
Right.
Well, the, the first one posits the telos, but the second, the better version posits that
positing, you know what I mean?
So, the, the, the best, the best, the Hegelian version of this is when you posit your own
presuppositions.
The, the first, the first simplicity is when the, the presupposition of the telos is entirely,
uh, it's internalized or nation or what, what's the word?
Like covert.
It's when you reflect on that positing function that you achieve, uh, I mean, he doesn't say,
use the language here, but some version of self-consciousness.
Yeah.
It's just, I mean, I get it and I get that there is a way to read this origin as not simply
an origin and yet it's, it's still sounds like, I mean, that's the critique of let's, we're
calling it Kant of the third move that is inadequate, you know, that, uh, um, so the, the, in,
in our translation, which is actually very close to yours and I didn't really glean anything
terribly noteworthy from your translation, um, is that living substance is being, which is
in truth subject or what is the same is in truth actual only so far as the movement of
positing itself or is the mediation of itself othering with itself.
This substance is as subject, pure, simple, negation, negativity.
And it's for this reason, the bifurcation of the simple.
It's the doubling which sets up opposition.
And then again, the negation of this indifferent diversity and of its antithesis, the antithesis
being the immediate, immediate simplicity.
Only this self-restoring sameness or this reflection of otherness back into itself, not an original
or immediate unity as such.
I mean, that's pretty clear, right?
In other words, like simplicity one, that's, you know, that's still Kant at, at, at best,
right?
Um, it is the true, right?
The otherness back into itself.
So it's weird because it's like, I mean, I guess you could kind of say that there really
is only one movement.
I mean, there's not, you know, there's just one movement.
It's just negation.
I mean, so we, we, we like to think of it in that triadic, you know, structure of points.
But the emphasis here, I mean, that, that's the, that's again where you go to it.
Sometimes it's, it's an occurrence and sometimes it's just a moment in the ladder of spirit.
And that, that toggling back and forth between those two things of, is there, are there points?
What is the value of the points?
Or is there relation?
And he wants to say, relationality is primary and relationality moves through points.
And that's the, you know, and so both of those things, um, seem, so yeah, the self-restoring
same as a reflection of otherness back into itself, not an original, original or immediate
unity as such is the true, I guess in some ways, wouldn't you want to say, I mean, I would
want to say, but then there could be no such thing as an original or immediate unity.
So why is it even an issue?
In other words, the things that people have been calling an original or immediate unity
never were.
So that, there is, there is no, and think, follow that out for a second.
That means there's no fucking immediacy, right?
There's no, there is no immediacy, which means that all the people that have been talking
about immediacy haven't been talking about immediacy.
Right?
So, so therefore there's no target there, right?
Like the, the, you lose the thing from which this is, I mean, I guess this is it.
There's such a concern with distinguishing his thinking from others' thinking, which is weird
given that the whole purpose of the thing should be indistinction.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, but, but this is the, but this is the unique quality of the negative is that, you
know, despite the fact that relationship is primary, it can only move by producing points
to move around.
That's right.
Yeah.
And so it's, and that, maybe that's what it sort of hinges on is the value or the function
or the place of the points, right?
Like, well, I mean, y'all have, have been really emphasizing, you know, is it Kant or is
it Schelling, which one's the bad term or which one's the more Hegelian term?
And I'm, I'm not reading that at all because, you know, frankly, I could swap in, I think
I could swap in almost any term and, and it doesn't really matter.
It's only the form that is getting set up here, which is that the, um, the true here
is the process of producing like otherness, which is a point, right?
Producing self, like the self alienated, um, other is a point that is, it's value is one
as a, as a proposition, it's never right.
So whether that's Spinoza or Schelling or, or, or Kant, who cares?
It's wrong, but that's the only thing that then allows it to be appropriated and then
have another negation spit out.
So I agree with you, John, that I think that, you know, the only real move is negation.
Then you could say as a by-product of negation, there are these sub points, which we could
say like positing is only ever, is never a, an affirmative move.
It's only ever a residue of a negation.
Right.
Yeah.
It could only be the, yeah, it's the, the necessity of the becoming reactive of man or of the philosopher
that he's articulating here.
And this is why this, I mean, it's, there's obviously a lot of tension.
between distinguishing, you know, Hegel distinguishing himself from Kant or from whoever, the intuitionist.
So, but that move is necessary for him to eventually make that synthesis move where no, everybody's
actually articulating a similar movement of thinking.
Because all the previous thinkers, right, and every philosopher to some extent is invested
in that differentiating move.
I'm, I have the answers, not the guy before me.
I'm the one with the true answers here.
Hegel's both articulating the impossibility of that gesture and his, you know.
It's, it's, it's, it's, it's necessity in his, his synthesizing move where he's like, everybody's
wrong all the time.
It's just that I'm the only one who's recognized that.
Yeah.
But see, that's what's valuable about that is, is it not understanding that they're wrong
because understanding that they're wrong isn't enough.
It's that recognizing how their wrongness allowed for a new negation to come about.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, again, like we, you guys have been teasing out, like, so you can't really just
simply say wrong and right or success and failure, but the language is still kind of operative
here, right?
So being wrong is not, being wrong is not simply being wrong.
You're also articulating a symptom that's inescapable in your wrongness, but that's, you
know, again, that's all part of this, this movement.
So, I mean, maybe, maybe another way then of saying what, what I'm uncomfortable with
there is that it, it's too slow, right?
You have to get to a point of realizing indistinction.
I'm like, why not just start there?
Like, why not, why, why do you have to start with distinctiveness in order to get to indistinction?
Because, I mean, I, I'll be honest with you, in terms of my work and my thinking and my writing,
that is a constant goal since I was a graduate student is to write things where I can't tell
where it's me and where it's Deleuze and where it's you guys or, you know what I mean?
Like, that for me is the goal, if there is one, of writing, like that, that kind of indistinction,
you know?
And I recognize the tension between that desire and a kind of marketplace which recognizes
individuals and the necessity, I mean, I remember, uh, um, Michael Barabay's response
to my dissertation was, um, I mean, this was that version of it, but it's pretty similar
to the book, but like, was, was pretty much like, okay, so, um, everybody's version of
change has been a problem and instead you're going to offer nothing new?
I don't see anyone really being interested in this project.
And I'm like, well, you certainly understood it because that's exactly what I, I want to
say.
Um, and so like, yeah, I want to, I want the upshot of my first book to be, there's nothing
new here.
You know?
Well, right.
You're, you're, you're reorienting toward the anxiety of influence, like the Harold Bloom
sort of notion, right?
So that's usually something, that's something that paralyzes people is where you're like,
Oh, my thinking is, is indistinguishable.
I have to make these cuts somehow.
And you're basically saying, well, you don't, you don't have to, I mean, that's, that's part
of the process.
It's necessary.
But I don't see a primacy between distinction and indistinction here just because, you know,
the indistinction of the notion only moves forward by producing distinctions only to have
them collapse back into a simple, uh, uh, a simplicity that's, again, so it doesn't seem
like you can start with indistinction or distinction, I think, for, for Hegel.
It doesn't matter as long as one produces the other.
Right.
But I mean, I, I think that there is this sense of, um, everything's going to fall back into
a simplicity, you know, uh, and everything is going to become simple.
It's just that some simple is better than other simples.
Um, and so.
Well, it's always the next simple that's better than the last simple.
Which would be.
Right.
Which would be like.
It's only because the, the, the, the next negation is producing a more, it is, um, producing
a more, more refined opposition.
Right.
But think of it, think of it this, I mean, this is sort of in, in that model, I think, like,
okay, at a certain point, like I begin to write and think, and it's me thinking.
One of the things that happens there is I read other things.
Let's just say I read Nietzsche.
And then what, you know, I incorporate it in, uh, whatever.
And then, and then I go on to write.
And when I'm writing, there's an indistinction between me and Nietzsche.
This is a, an elevated, uh, uh, self beyond when it was just me.
Now it's me and Nietzsche.
Then I go further and I read scholarship on Nietzsche.
Then it's me, Nietzsche, and interlocutors that are all a melange in there together.
And if you keep increasing that, then it becomes the world, right?
It becomes every, everyone and everything are a component.
It becomes spirit in that sense, right?
Isn't that what spirit is?
It's the perpetual incorporation of all diversity and otherness into an indistinction that we're
calling subject here.
But the, the subject would no longer be me, right?
The, the subject would be spirit as this kind of imminent transcendent, you know, I know
that makes no sense to say both of those words together.
Well, but you know, this is where the in itself and the for itself are basically synonymous.
Like, so if spirit is both in itself and for itself, those are indistinguishable movements.
The for itself, when you, when you add that little, uh, twist on it, that means that spirit
always has investments that are, that are guarded basically.
And so thought, if thought is, thought is in itself, it's the only thing in town, thought
conceptuality.
That's the thing in itself, not the Kantian thing in itself.
If it's also for itself, that means we can never access it as such.
It's not transparent.
It has investments that are guarded that you can never like truly unravel.
Um, so the movement of thinking, um, which is the thing in itself is never accessible to
the philosopher.
Right.
So I can't, I can't parse out where it's me and where it's Nietzsche and where it's
you guys or whatever.
Like it is this sort of blurred melange of, of, of a bunch of us.
Why the fuck do I say that?
Well, this is also why I'm thinking, this is why I keep on using the language of paradigm
and not persons.
And why I, I have a harder time taking up the example, like me reading, because, um, the,
I don't think the diversity holds here that I, for Hegel, just because, um, you know, I
am what, whatever I'm going to call me is really just an expression of spirit.
And I am nothing more than self alienate part of the self alienation project or, um, projection
of, of spirit writ large.
So beginning with me doesn't make sense, which is why I start with more like the spirit of
an age, and I am just the manifestation of that spirit, self alienation.
Um, yeah, I mean, it sort of doesn't matter.
It's just a question of incorporating, produce generating, and incorporating otherness, right?
So you have here multiplicity.
It's just generated by the self, right?
It's generated by the subject, right?
That multiplies are alternative.
So, so otherness is self alienation, you know?
Um, and so.
But I would even say not self alienation of me.
It's not, I don't self alienate, but spirit self alienates.
Well, spirit.
Yeah, that's fine.
Kind of self alienation of spirit, but that, I mean, but this is just where the transcendence
operates.
It's, it's, it's, the transcendence is always imminently operative, right?
Like nothing doesn't have a direct tie back to the transcendent movement of, of spirit.
There is no local, there are no local movements, right?
There are no idiosyncrasies.
Everything is directly.
Well, not from the point of view, depends on the point of view, wouldn't it?
Like from the point of view of spirit, correct.
Right.
But from, from the point of view of like a person thinking, you know, of course there
would be, you know, all kinds of.
No, I would say that, like, I would say from their perspective, sure, but then they're wrong.
And I, I, I've not read anything about this, but the phrase that Zizek's phrase that, that
Nate threw around a few times is that seems to be like, live your symptom.
You are a symptom of the negation of spirit.
Enjoy your symptom, right?
That, I don't know if that's, that resonates if I'm just totally, of course it's appropriate.
That's, that's, I mean, that's, that's Lacan.
I mean, he, he's, he's writing on Lacan there, but, but the, the logic of Lacan, I mean, it
is, it's the same logic.
You're not wrong there.
Yeah.
I mean, that's, that's, that's your only option from that perspective is to enjoy being
a symptom because that's what you are.
Right.
Yeah.
And you, like, it's pretty odd, like you'd want, you want another option other than that.
So like, you think you do, you think you do.
I mean, you think you want a freedom from an autonomy or something, but that's, that is
the symptom.
That's the symptom.
Exactly.
The symptom is that I don't want to be a symptom.
The pursuit of autonomy is that.
But, but it explains the reactions against both Lacan and Hegel.
Cause it's like, if it, if it's truly inescapable, the symptomatology, it's like, well then
like, if you, if you kind of just give yourself up to that, then there is no possibility for
like positive self-transformation.
It's, it, there's always going to be, it's both inevitable and inconceivable.
Right.
So you're always going to change.
Change is inevitable.
Inevitable and inconceivable.
That's good.
Things are going to shift.
The world's going to change, but you have nothing to do with that.
Like you, your, your intentions or motivations, you know, are incorporated into that movement.
They're not outside of it.
And there's no, you know, there's no, there's no, there's no, there's no room for intention
in this, in this system.
Right.
Or it's explained as, as a symptom or as a residue of that, of that larger, quote unquote,
larger.
The enjoyment that I get in trying to assert my intention is nothing more than a momentary
expression of spirit and therefore a symptom itself.
Right.
But I, I mean, I, I still come back.
I, I, another way of saying another, you know, way of articulating my reservation is it's like
there's too much being in this version of becoming.
Like there are too many moments, you know, why does there have to be a step-by-step process
of points?
Like what happens if you just say there really aren't any points ever, which is to say, if
you do, if you speed up the Hegelian dialectic and you say it's not like, for instance, his
history of philosophy, you know, which is, you know, the pre-Socratics were the subjectivists
and Plato was the objectivist and Aristotle was the synthesis and Aquinas was, I mean, that's
how he tells the story of, of the history of philosophy, which is a sort of world historical
story.
So, so to me, I mean, rather than thinking of spirit's sort of developmental world historical
process, why not just be like, there's, it's all spirit all the time, always completely fulfilled,
right, always, you know, and so there is no, in that sense, that's a kind of pure being
of pure becoming, you know, that it, that's not, that's not historical, it's not subject
to time, right?
It's not like, first there was this, or it's not, you don't say, not an original or immediate
unity as such is the true, it's like, well, then there was, there is no immediate, there
is no original and there is no immediate unity, there is only, you know, absolute negation,
and this is what it looks like, by the way, it's not something we get to.
Thank you.